so for narcissism what you get is a big
dollop of antagonism
kind of mean and self-centered and then
you add that extraversion piece to it so
you take
you know low agreeableness and
extroversion that's a recipe for
grandiose narcissism
take that same low agreeableness or
meanness or callousness
add neuroticism anxiety depression
and you end up with vulnerable
narcissism
we're talking about narcissism today
word that gets
thrown around quite a lot like what is
the correct definition of it and how
does it manifest
well you're right the terms used a lot
um
the most basic sort of foundational
definition is
somebody who has a very positive view of
him or herself
a lack of empathy and a need for
admiration so that's that like
in a nutshell when you talk about
narcissism you're usually talking about
a positive self you think you're better
than other people
you have some challenges with forming
close
caring empathetic relationships with
people
and you need people around to kind of
boost you up to bolster you to admire
you to give you a positive attention etc
so that's kind of the general
term um when people are used in the
street they're often using it in a bit
of a pejorative way to describe an
ex-boyfriend or an ex-boss or whatever
so it's
you know so people i don't really use it
technically right
but then when you get into the
psychology and the science part there's
really
you can break it down farther into
really three different definitions of
narcissism
um the one we're probably most familiar
with is the personality trait
and when i say trait i mean that this is
something we all vary on there's a
continuum some are more narcissistic
some less
most people around the middle there's a
trait called grandiose narcissism which
is this
um sort of sense of self importance and
a sense of entitlement but with
grandiose narcissism what you see is
some
energy and maybe charisma sometimes
charm
and drive and ambition so the more
grandiose narcissist folks you meet are
the ones that
end up and you know in politics or in
leadership
because they have this drive and
ambition and they're often very likable
people when you first meet them and you
don't see that the darker more
toxic side of narcissism until later on
there's another form of narcissism which
is less familiar to most of us but it's
when you see more with
counselors and clinicians and you know
in the mental health world
it's what we call vulnerable narcissism
so these are people who have the same
sense of entitlement but rather than be
more
ambitious and energized they're a little
more
nervous have low self-esteem a little
more introverted
sometimes called covert narcissists or
basement narcissists or in the closet
narcissist because you have
and so you have a fantasy about being
successful
but there's not really energy or drive
to make that real
so so and so you you can imagine if you
think you're great and you're not out
there engaging with the world you have a
tendency for depression
and anxiety and loneliness because
you're not getting what you need
so the more vulnerable folks end up in
the clinical settings more
and then to make it even more confusing
there's a clinical or psychiatric
disorder
known as narcissistic personality
disorder npd
and this is an extreme form of
narcissism that's grandiose and a little
vulnerable
and what happens is your narcissism gets
so extreme
it impairs you in life it either
destroys your relationships because you
can't have loving relationships with
people
or it ruins your work because you take
too many risks or you're a terrible boss
so you can't listen to people or
whatever
and then it becomes a disorder but
that's relatively rare
where the confusion comes in is people
say you're a narcissist and you're like
what do you mean do you mean i'm kind of
a cool dude who's got a lot of
girlfriends or do you mean i'm kind of a
loser at my mom's home on the internet
trolling people trying to get attention
or do you mean i have some i'm somebody
with a clinical disorder who should see
a psychiatrist and be treated
and so we that's where a lot of
confusion comes in is the different
the different definitions that are
associated with narcissism
it's interesting that you can have one
trait
one sort of source code that is
underwriting the way that someone is
created and yet when that tree starts to
grow up
it can lean to one of a number of
different ways and create a variety of
shapes
that is a very interesting way to to put
it and i think
um part of it is that that ego that's if
you think about the source code of like
ego i want attention i'm better than
people
if you if you pair that with somebody
who's got some social skills and whose
parents said you're awesome keith you're
great
and who has some confidence that person
can become a successful sort of
grandiose narcissist
but that same characteristics but the
person was maybe abused or traumatized
the parents you know not
incredible trauma parents that were more
cold and dismissive
who didn't have the social skills ends
up on this more
um vulnerable path so you could see that
idea how you could bend these different
forms in different ways but they're both
very ego based
i read uh robert ploman's blueprint last
year
talking about the influence of genetics
on
everything that we do with regards to
behavior and i think that your
findings with narcissism match up with
what he said it's around about 50
percent
is nature and 50 percent is nurture
yeah that's um it's funny i remember
studying
him in graduate school um have you read
blueprint have you read this new one
i haven't no i think if you would it's
really good
uh yeah i mean being honest there is
a couple of takeaways that you'll
already have and they are
every trait has significant and
sizable influence from our genetics like
that's the
the big red pill but as you go into
stuff like
in adoption studies weight is completely
correlated between biological parents
and not at all through the adopted
parents
like which is crazy especially when we
live in a world that's a meritocracy
um but yeah so talking about uh genetic
about the genetic influence on
narcissism yeah so
you find that pattern with narcissism
that you and so generally you're getting
about 50 percent like you're saying
about 50
is is inherited it might be narcissism
in terms of traits seems to be a little
bit on the higher side but it
you know they're all about 50 when you
look at that other piece
about 10 to 20 percent is parenting
maybe 10 percent so the parenting piece
is never as important as people think
you know the people think parenting is
really shaping you parenting matters a
lot your parents have to feed you
and love you and do all these things but
they can't really shape you that well to
be one kind of person or another
the other piece that that's really hard
to predict in this about 30 percent
maybe is just what they call non-shared
environments just sort of the culture
you grow up with the friends you have
the weird random stuff that happens and
that seems to be what's going on with
narcissism so there is some genetics but
that's certainly not the whole story and
the other pieces are a bit harder to
find
why does it exist like the trait must
have had an adaptive use
why is it here yeah
well um
you can think about that that's a hard
question to answer so the few ways to
think about it one
is you can go well what are the benefits
of narcissism where does it really
benefit you
and when we think about evolutionary
terms we usually think about sort of
resource gathering or mating
those are kind of the big evolutionary
questions narcissism
is linked to short-term mating success
so people are narcissistic are good at
finding mates
they're good at becoming leaders very
quickly so it has some
maybe very short-term advantages
the challenge and this is where it gets
complicated with with the evolutionary
models is
if you're if you evolved in a small
group at trial you know we're talking 50
000 years ago you've got your group of
50 100 people and
you're the narcissistic jerk who's who's
who's hooking up with everyone else's
spouses
they're going to kill you i mean that's
just what happened if you look at the
hundred gathered tribes
they'd have somebody in your family take
you on a walk and you just wouldn't come
back there'd be a hunting accident
you know there'd be so these more
psychopathic individuals were weeded out
in those smaller cultures
often but you imagine when a culture
gets bigger
you you live in a big city a big urban
center
there's no check on ego there's no check
on narcissism
it thrives better but i think that the
narcissism is really beneficial in sort
of new situations in the short term
where you don't see the benefit is in
these long-term established
relationships
it's just not as useful yeah so in a
society
or a a community where you are
held to account over longer periods of
time the narcissist is going to lose
but in shorter interactions that sounds
a lot like
the way that psychopaths work that they
can never stay in a town for one for too
long because
they screw over people and they realize
who they are are all
psychopaths narcissistic and how does
narcissism and psychopathy
relate yeah they're um their cousin
traits in a way
what psychopathy and narcissism share is
this
interpersonal we call antagonism or
interpersonal callousness the
willingness to take advantage of people
and put yourself first
looking out for number one so that's
something that's very common with
psychopathy and narcissism
really the difference is with narcissism
you get more of that interest in
attention or positive feedback from
other people
so often narcissists aren't as dangerous
because they they still want to be loved
um so okay where's the psychopath
the psychopath is simply out to get
whatever they want at any cost
whereas perhaps there's a little bit
more somewhere in the background there's
an
echo of a um virtue or in integrity even
if that's only
outcome based for example for the
narcissist
yeah so so the psychopaths i think of is
more predatory
like i mean and again these these things
will like if i gave
a group of psychopathy measures and
narcissism measures to people
in a lab they're going to correlate very
i mean they're going to correlate
strongly
their cousin traits and sometimes we
talk about a dark triad of traits
that include psychopathy narcissism and
this other one which is
machiavellianism which is named after
machiavelli wrote the book the prince
it's it's a characteristic of people who
are really manipulative
so they're not necessarily attention
seeking they're not necessarily
they don't necessarily want to just
steal stuff or get stuff they're more
manipulative
but they all share this core
of antagonism or callousness or a
willingness to exploit other people for
your own ends
i wanted to dig into the dark triad
reason being the first time i got
introduced to it i was reading
a menanism blog
so part of this red pill movement the
pro
men so it's essentially a men's rights
movement
on this particular blog and i found it
fascinating some of the stuff that they
put out
was really interesting and then there's
an entire
that there's reams and reams dedicated
to cultivating dark triad traits
so they basically say that having those
dark triad traits
will allow you to be more resilient a
lot of these people
in these realms are perhaps divorced
perhaps um involuntarily celibate
someone who maybe doesn't succeed
socially so well
um first off what is it can you dig into
the dark triad and then secondly can you
imagine why someone in that situation
would need it or even think about trying
to develop it
that's really interesting um and i'm
kind of it's kind of clicking when you
say it so i'm not
i haven't really thought this through
obviously but
when we talk about these dark triad
traits these are traits that
sure uh that share a core of darkness
and darkness and psychology would we
call low agreeableness
or callousness or maybe trait antagonism
maybe easiest way is meanness people are
mean so dark people are mean people
that's probably an easy way to say say
it and they're different kinds of mean
the challenge with men in relationships
sometimes as you hear men say well
[ __ ] always get the girls
yeah okay so all be an [ __ ] now if
you study what an
[ __ ] is an [ __ ] is somebody who is
callous
low in agreeableness and has dark traits
basically an [ __ ] is right at the
center
center of the dark triad that's kind of
what an [ __ ] means somebody is a jerk
is antagonistic and mean self-centered
so people think that's what people want
that's not what people want
i mean there's no research i've ever
seen that says you know what i really
want is somebody's just an [ __ ]
that's really what i want my life
when you look at the narcissism research
in dating
people aren't and i'll say women but it
goes both ways obviously but women are
dating narcissists because they're jerks
they're dating narcissists because they
seem confident
and charismatic and attractive and
exciting to be with
at first the problem is
over time when you're dating somebody
who's charismatic and exciting to be
with you go okay now is the point in the
relationship we're going to get to know
each other and be more emotional and
talk about having kids
and the guy's like yeah i don't really
want to do that part in the relationship
where'd you get that idea i'm really
kind of into me
and into having fun and it's cool to
have you with me but i didn't want to
settle down
and then she goes well you're an [ __ ]
well
yeah but i'm also kind of fun and
charismatic and you like that part of me
you like the part that makes me fun and
cares you don't like the [ __ ] part
that's what you don't like about me
so people so guys watch this and go my
goodness that woman's with an ass will
all be an [ __ ]
no you should be charismatic
and engaging and have a sense of humor
take care of yourself
and to have some confidence don't be an
[ __ ] but that message gets really
distorted but
this isn't my area chris oh man you've i
think you've hit the nail on the head
it's putting the cart before the horse
it's presuming that the emergent
property of the narcissism
which is effective needs to go actually
in fact it's baby in bath water
it's i need to be a narcissist in order
to have the charisma
so there's a few things that you said at
the beginning of that little passage
um there's a quote from the red pill
movement alpha
[ __ ] and beta cooks so it's that the
alpha male will get it and
she'll make rules for the beta that she
breaks for the alpha
and all of this is built around this
sort of cult of alpha maleness
right and a lot of this you would be
fascinated
by some of the red pill movement and
meninism blogs that are out there
our slash men's rights on uh reddit has
a lot of this stuff on there
and um yeah it's it's interesting
especially upon reading
your work how the narcissism
side of it has been
utilized by people it's been uh
glorified
by people as a tool that should be used
that should be cultivated
because it's going to cause especially a
lot of these people i think
have been hurt by women perhaps in the
past or never had success with women
which has also caused them to be hurt
um so by by increasing that
narcissism they're increasing the
distance
between them emotionally between them
and the other people
and that's where the this blend that you
said before of
uh vulnerable and grandiose grandiose
narcissism so it's outwardly being
grandiose because of inward
vulnerability
i'm trying to protect myself from being
hurt by seeming like i don't give a [ __ ]
and never fully investing in people
that's interesting so so
if it makes me think of four things i'll
probably forget the second
but first when we talk about
callousness you know you think about a
callus a callus works both ways
which i never think about because i
think about callousness is i treat
people
callously but also means i can't feel as
much
and what you're saying is these people
are wounded and so they develop a
callous like i'm not going to let myself
be wounded
now the reason we call vulnerable
narcissism and grandiose narcissism both
narcissism is
back in the psychodynamic days the
freudian days you know you go back
50 100 years people thought that what
was on the outside of you was almost the
opposite of the inside
just they thought that's the way the
mind worked so that
gee if you seem really confident
underneath you're probably weak
it doesn't really work like that in
general life they're people who are
confident they're people who are weak
and there's some people who are both but
most confident people are just kind of
confident
but what you're describing is a very
freudian process almost where people
are they feel weak they feel they can't
succeed with women
they see other people or they go you
know what i'm going to be i'm going to
toughen up
and grow a shell and then enact in sort
of an aggressive and confident way maybe
and that will
convince women to like me and i can't
get hurt because i've got this big shell
around me
yeah it's that mimetic quality that we
have right we're trying to
reflect what we see with with people
yeah i'll send you some i'll send you
some article links once we're done i
think you'd be really interested in
looking at it very
so my my child with a lot of these when
they think about so the other thing is
alpha males
now i um i i don't get the alpha male
thing so much i remember i was in africa
and i
looked at it i was looking at this group
of gazelles
and i was with this guy and he goes well
here's the alpha
what does the alpha do well the alpha
spends a year guarding every woman in
his harem
from guys until he gets exhausted and
dies in a year or two
because it's being an alpha male it
kills you
i mean that alpha males in nature
they they just kind of die out and the
fact is humans
we're much more balanced than that we
don't really work with these really
strong
alpha hierarchies like a lot of other
creatures do
and so the idea of wanting to be an
alpha male i'm like
dude that's a lot it's a cult
of personality now that term on the
internet is thrown around by a very
large minority of men in a particular
type of thought pool
as the pinnacle of what you're supposed
to become
as a man and i think another another
part of it
in terms of the alpha male thing is
is just being confused about the metrics
of success
because the interesting thing with
narcissism as far as i see it and
specifically with being an alpha male
is that outwardly you have all of the
trappings of success
and because i'm never going to get to
see your internal scorecard
it almost doesn't matter so this ruse i
think is promulgated
in a number of ways one by people that
are narcissists and alpha males
having that outward success secondly by
them never
seeming like they suffer with criticism
so they almost seem invulnerable to it
and then thirdly that they will begin to
believe their own [ __ ] after a while
but the bottom line we don't know what
conor mcgregor or elon musk
or some alpha male red pill pickup
artistry guy
what the thoughts inside of his head are
like when they go to sleep on a night
time when you put your head on the
pillow
no one gets to see that but we we
observe the objective metrics of success
the instagram followers the wealth the
girls
yeah in psychology we have we call it
sort of
extrinsic or external values or motives
or goals and
intrinsic values and goals and extrinsic
ones with narcissism the
easiest way to remember this is sex
status and stuff you want
sex you want to have high social status
and you want material
goods that show people like i saw that
mcgregor guy with his million dollar
watch
and it kind of looked cheesy man i'm a
watch guy i didn't even like the million
dollar watch but
guys got a million dollar watch looks
cooler than i
am um but that's that um
but but it but when you regulate
extrinsically
it look i'm not telling anyone not to go
for it in life
please go for it please be as much as
you can i've tried you know
but know that when you start competing
to be the best at sex status and stuff
one
you're always competing you're never
going to win because as soon as you get
to the top someone you're going to be
knocked off and someone else will be
so that's just the nature of it you've
been in entertainment you know i've been
in
you know you just that's the nature of
it you can't be on the top forever
unless you're a country music star in
the 50s in america
um and and you're going to get knocked
off and you're going to die alone
and that's the worst part you can't have
love
and so what happens is you see guys that
get you know they're my age and they're
kind of like going where's the love
i don't have any love in my life yeah
because you're you're an arrogant dick
and you've got all this great stuff and
you got a million dollar watch but you
don't have any love
yeah and you can't buy that you can't
buy a happy family you can pretend you
have one you can't pay
so there's this you get this really
foundational loss
in terms of emotional connection and
that's the
cost you know what else it is as well
thinking further into this
a lot of the people who are
proselytizing
about the the virtues of being an alpha
male
are guys in their 40s or in their 50s or
in their late 50s
who are almost acting like these savant
sages of masculinity
who are talking about how it should be
done
but they're playing a game that someone
20 years their junior
should be playing and by the time that
you get to 50 you can't get in the mix
with 21 year olds in a nightclub anymore
you need a family around you you need
people that uh it doesn't scale that's a
perfect way to look at it narcissism
doesn't scale across a lifetime
and all of the things that you do should
compound as
uh appreciating assets not depreciating
ones
um the equivalent for guys choosing
girls
is choose a girl that is beautiful it
doesn't matter how hot she is hotness
wanes with age beauty increases with age
i i like that way of
um framing it and what you see with uh
these sort of the more dominant
narcissist folks is they'll start one
family and then they'll wait 10 years
and when they're 50 they'll just redo
it and then they'll wait 10 years and do
it again
and so um like my dissertation was on
trophy spouses i was kind of interested
in
you know what my my instagram bio is
aspiring trophy husband it's perfect
right
not a bad plan you know it works
um but but the idea is that you kind of
replicate this pattern over and over
but you know by the time you're 60 and
you got a one-year-old with the new wife
it just looks i'm like oh my god that
just sounds exhausting
i mean so i um
i just like i said i love success i'm
i love masculinity i'm saying go for it
do what you're gonna do but this
alpha thing is just i think it's a bit
misguided
i agree um what does narcissism have to
do with mass shootings you looked at
elliott roger
as an example can you talk about how
manifest uh narcissism manifested
through him
yeah so um i'm gonna i'll step it back
a second to to columbine if that's okay
because that's really um where we
started
with this in the narcissism world so if
um
so when i i was doing research this is
back in the 90s and i was at
doing a post-doc with a friend named
jean twangy we're in our basement lab
and
there was the shooting at columbine
which in the u.s was a big deal this is
these two
boys went and shot up a school in
colorado
and then afterwards they said you know i
can't
spielberg's gonna make a movie about me
or taratino
and i can make anybody remem think
anything i want and
we read this stuff and we're like oh my
god these guys are using words straight
off the narcissistic personality
inventory
that's weird so we started like why are
people doing these shootings what's the
point
so we started looking at it and what you
see and this is part of the story in
these shootings is you find people who
are threatened you get
ego threat they call it or self-esteem
threat or jeff
generally feel that they're not up to
they're not alpha males like in the case
of elliot rogers you know this is a case
in santa barbara with a guy who
asked a woman on a date she rejected him
he's like no one you know
everyone's rejecting me i'm going to
show him who the real alpha male is and
then he went and killed some of his
friends and
um so what happens is you see these
these young guys
it's often guy usually guys uh they get
ego threats and then to establish
dominance what they do is don't commit a
mass shooting
they'll maybe write a manifesto with it
so i've read a lot of these they're very
dark but often the manifestos but how i
should be in charge of the world it
should work for me
um anyway
you see this pattern in a lot of those
shootings in the case of elliot rogers i
thought it was very interesting as well
because
he was a a kid who had a lot of money
and power his parents were very
successful he was a good-looking dude
i think he had a bmw he should have been
able to date he should have been able to
function in the world he couldn't
and his his way of of dealing with that
was to literally resort to mass shooting
he worked it out in his head that the
best way for him to reestablish
dominance in a world that didn't accept
him was to go kill people
so that's where you you get that um
where you get that uh narcissism school
shootings is the shootings themselves
are a way to
to re-establish dominance and often if
there's a manifesto
or something it's a way of becoming a
great figure these people like a lot of
serial killers they're
high status successful people i hate to
say successful but they're famous
um because you can use murder to get
successful
i wonder whether the alpha male cult
that we've got at the moment is using
sex weaponizing sex in the same way well
i haven't won the world in the way that
i think it should be
should be won perhaps they don't have
the compulsion to go shoot up a school
but they have the compulsion to use and
abuse uh
the the opposite sex or the same sex
depending on i'm gonna guess there must
be
there must be narcissistic alpha males
in the gay world as well i'd be really
interested
to any of the gay guys that are
listening i'd be really fascinated to
know if there's more there you mentioned
something
just during that passage does narcissism
skew male
1 yes yeah does grandiose narcissism uh
skews male vulnerable narcissism is
about
50 50 and the person in the personality
disorder is about three-quarters male
1 wow that really is a male-dominated
trait then
yeah it's the but but some of this is
you know you you think about
clinical diagnosis and they they tend to
gender some
diagnoses so you know if the two people
come in and a man they'll say well
you're narcissistic and a little
vulnerable and a woman they'll say well
you're borderline
and a little self-centered so sometimes
they
they will they will place people a
little bit i mean there could be some
gender but but generally narcissism is
more masculine
trait how do you measure it well if
you're measuring it
as uh in a personality form like if you
want to take your own narcissism or if i
were doing a study there's a bunch of
scales
that the most common one is called the
narcissistic personality inventory you
could google it and it's not you know
it's 40 questions the most common form
there's other vulnerable narcissism
scales like the hyper-sensitive
narcissism scale
there's a bunch of them for clinical so
when you do normal personality testing
it's called low stakes meaning people
will tell the truth because what do they
care they're just taking an anonymous
survey
if you're doing clinical work it's
harder or if you're working in a
in a foreign like if you're working in a
in a uh
a prison system a forensic system it's
harder because people don't want to tell
you the truth
so if you're going to a clinical setting
and you're getting diagnosed they might
do a structured interview
well they'll sit down ask you questions
and and kind of go through it that way
to do a more formal diagnosis
um what's the narcissism recipe
so when i think about personality traits
this is a bigger answer but there's
personality traits
are kind of captured in languages
adjectives
so whenever you use adjectives to
describe somebody you're often talking
about personality they're
quick-witted and hot-tempered and a
little
zany so those are all kind of
personality traits
and when you when personality
psychologists over the last decade you
know starting with
um you know galton and in your country
i'm started trying to chunk these traits
up they said well let's start
moving same together well somebody who's
creative and
curious and zany those are probably
similar somebody's nice and kind and
caring those are similar start chunking
them up
when you do that you end up with five
traits
they call the big five and
so those big five traits which are i'm
going to just tell you i know
openness to experience conscientiousness
or which is dutifulness
extroversion or energy agreeableness or
niceness
and neuroticism or instability you know
so
they spell ocean if you ever want to
remember or canoe
what you can do with those basic traits
is you can combine them i always think
of like
you know mexican food you go to a
mexican place you're like yeah i want a
taco or a
same ingredients you just kind of
organize them differently it's the same
with personality you take these basic
ingredients
and you organize them so for narcissism
what you get is a big dollop of
antagonism
kind of mean and self-centered and then
you add that extraversion piece to it
so you take you know low agreeableness
and extroversion that's a recipe for
grandiose narcissism
take that same low agreeableness or
meanness or callousness
add neuroticism anxiety depression
and you end up with vulnerable
narcissism does that make sense
so that's the idea that you can use
these basic traits
to make more complicated traits we talk
about a trait like psychopathy
is really primarily just antagonism
it's really in the big five it's just a
big piece of that antagonism that's sort
of carved up in a certain way
yeah so what this allows us to do is
personality psychologists is
whatever the trade is we can take that
trait put it into big five terms and
then translate it into whatever trade we
want it's a bit of a rosetta stone for
our traits
i mean this is getting a little nerdy
but that's kind of how we do it i get it
what's the goals and motives
for a narcissist well
you know it's really it really comes
down in terms of the broader goals to
sex
status and stuff that's where a lot of
it can be framed into getting leadership
positions getting power getting money
getting
access to the vulnerable one
yeah yeah i mean it's just they're just
scared to do it
the motivational structure is the same
but they're but they don't have the
drive see
so in the in the old you know in the old
psychoanalytic literature they'd say you
know to be really narcissistic you have
to be really talented or really
attractive
because if you're really attractive or
really talented people will let you get
away with it
so people are vulnerable have the they
have the goals
they want to be successful but they it's
scary for them and
so let me give you a specific example
selfies
so selfies you know we started studying
selfies when this you know five ten
years ago when this i guess
it's been about yeah it's almost 10
years since people started taking self
it's been a while
um and what we found with selfies are
people
grandiose narcissists they take selfies
very easily because they like themselves
they're happy to show their abs they're
more
full body and they're more alone and
they and they don't have any problems
sharing selfies it's just kind of what
they do
people who are vulnerable want to take
selfies too
but when they do it they don't really
like what they see
they get anxious it's not as much fun
for them so it's very challenging so if
you talk to influencers who have more
vulnerability
maybe you do i don't i haven't talked to
that many influencers
um but when you talk to people it's very
painful they're like i had to put this
picture out of myself on instagram
i wasn't sure if i was hot enough it's i
want to be hot it's a real struggle for
me
so that's the problem with the
vulnerability is is like you you want to
be out there
but you've got all this concern and
neuroticism that's kind of keeping you
back
yeah let's let's talk about social media
i've got i've got
some thoughts in my mind about that i
really want to dig into but i want to
kind of close the loop to the social
media world at the moment
have you guys been tracking narcissism
through the advent of social media has
there been a
statistically significant increase can
we say that social media is feeding
narcissism or is it just is it just
enabling narcissism
so it's a little bit more complicated
than that i think historically because
when we first started looking at this
and and jean twang and i wrote a book
called the narcissism epidemic like
a decade ago into 2000 into the great
recession so it's by 12th
and at that point we saw narcissism
really spiking up with college students
and
social media and i really thought that
there was this dynamic feedback loop
going on where the social media is
really encouraging narcissism
and maybe it was but then what we
started noticing
is we started seeing these very negative
sort of side effects of social media
especially in girls
where they'd report a lot of social
comparison processes
so like i am online and i look at my
friend and she's so happy
and looks so attractive and i'm not so i
feel bad or
fear of missing out like fomo so people
get on
social media like god these people are
so happy and i'm not at the party and so
it's almost like social media started
making people depressed in a way
and we saw a change of uh people go from
instagram to
fence to fake instagram to snapchat to
tick tock
so they're kind of moving away from the
social pressure
um at the same time
when you look at the research on
narcissism and social media it seems to
be self-reinforcing which is kind of
what you hinted at that people are
narcissistic use it and it reinforces
their narcissism so i put out my insta
post everybody likes me
i go god i'm pretty hot i'm going to do
it again that's reinforcing but it's not
turning you into a narcissist it's sort
of reinforcing what's there
so my guess is there's a lot going on
here
it's individually reinforcing but at the
cultural level it's having these
these side effects that aren't
necessarily
predicted or aren't always feeding the
direction of narcissism
jonathan heights work on that in the
cuddling of the american mind was so
scary
there's for the people that haven't seen
it there's essentially a graph that
talks about
is it anxiety disorder and depressive
sort of episodes amongst teenage girls
like precisely the ones that you want to
give sympathy to
you know like a 13 year old girl that
feels anxious and depressed it's just
you know you just want to make them feel
better
yeah um and it's the advent of instagram
2012 i think you just see
it's like a line in the graph like
tesla's stock price last year
there's just this line yeah exactly and
it just lifts off
one of the interesting takeaways from
that was to do with the fact that
girls use words
and more social backstabbing techniques
in order to deal with disputes
and the hypothesis that
jonathan suggested for why that wasn't
happening with guys
is that guys will just throw hands and
then
pick themselves up off the floor and so
then you're best friends with the guy
that you just had a fight with five
minutes later
but because girls don't necessarily have
that physical outlet naturally
that has caused the increase in
depression and anxiety
i i think there's that you know
sometimes people talk about like cyber
bullying or whatever that you can get
those
indirect negative uh effects
and the other thing to add to what
you're saying that makes it even worse
is in the old days if everyone hated you
you could move to the next town
and change your name and start school
again and no one would know who you were
but now you know your social identity
follows you so these kids it's very hard
to escape
some of the bowling and stuff if it gets
bad so
it can be dark yeah i think yeah let's
think about
the three s's the sex status and stuff
which i love
to remember what narcissism happened
what narcissism's there for
social media has permitted everybody to
ubiquitously communicate their sex their
status and their stuff
here's a photo of me with my girlfriend
wearing my brand new watch
and i've got an extra 100 followers than
i did yesterday which is 10 000 more
than you've got
yes yeah i um i've described it
this way and i don't know if it makes
sense but i'll try it with you is
bitcoin and those kind of crypto
networks work on mining so you have
people that are actually
you know using computer power to solve
algorithms and that what keeps the
network going
with something like instagram what you
need are influencers those are people
who are out there getting you know who
are attractive people who are getting
attention
mining attention yeah mine you need
attention miners
and they're the ones keeping the network
going if it weren't for people out there
attention
seeking attention the networks would
drop
but facebook rather than paying those
people directly in bitcoin like like
you know cryptos do they they they do it
indirectly they pay
in dopamine they pay you in dopamine
sort of like being paid in cocaine you
know when it stops it's really bad yeah
and so that's so that's how i look at
these systems that they're they're
that narcissism is kind of integral to
the function it's not the whole thing
because rage is really an important
thing but if you look at what's shared
it's it's rage humor
ego and uh and that's how these networks
are built
so they need i mean instagram
you need influencers for the network to
work
and they're the miners of the network so
they're kind of like ego networks in a
way
did that make sense absolutely a little
bit yeah yeah i like that
so what i want to try and talk about is
the relationship between
talent and narcissism so
what i find particularly interesting is
that narcissism
with talent comes across as justified
charisma
conor mcgregor is a good example of this
right you know for all that he lost
a couple of fights recently won against
the greatest boxer of all time and won
against arguably the greatest mma
fighter of all time
he's a guy that is just brimming with
extroversion and charisma
is there some nas i don't know whether
many people would call him narcissistic
however let's do a thought experiment
and in another world
conor mcgregor has all of the same
extroversion and charisma that he has
but has lost every single fight that
he's ever had
his charisma and extroversion haven't
changed at all the things he's saying
are the same
it's the justification based on talent
which has
and yet far more people would accuse
that version of him of being a
narcissist
what's going on right because
i think if you're if you're successful
enough people think you deserve it
so colin mcgregor is a great fighter so
it can be an arrogant jerk
um i'm not saying that's true but that's
you know that would make sense
like yeah you know you're a king you can
be an arrogant jerk you
you just you got the status to do it but
if you don't have the status then you're
just a poser you're worse than me and
you're acting like you're conor mcgregor
you're i mean you're not him you're
worse than i am i hate you
so i there is that that piece of status
but the other thing that i think is
important is that
you can be really successful in
athletics or any and you don't have to
be an arrogant jerk
and in fact um people will like you even
more
if you're not an arrogant jerk and
your career is going to be better in the
long term because you're going to build
relationships on the way
and then when you you know when he
transitions from being a fighter
into something else if he had
relationships
and maybe he's got two kids now yeah
yeah he's got family
married two kids yeah i i shouldn't i
don't know the guy but i mean it's
it's just if you're that arrogant it's
hard it's gonna be harder to transition
when you're no longer the celebrity
and celebrity is very short so there
must be
there must be a way to weaponize or to
utilize and have
charisma extroversion uh
self-belief outwardly focused without it
being
narcissism where does that line lie yeah
i i
i think it's really the interpersonal
piece so you can be confident
and extroverted but you walk into the
gym and instead of like you're
instead of saying like i can do better
do you like you go to the weak guy and
you go hey let me help you out
like dude mcgregor helped me out at the
gym yeah he's a good guy he kind of took
the time to help me out
and all of a sudden everyone's talking
about what a legend you are
so you can be nice you don't have to be
you know you don't
you're the best like everyone knows you
don't have to prove yourself
so i think that i mean i've been at the
university of georgia which is
i mean you wouldn't know in england but
we have a lot of world-class athletes
just nature of a college big football
program
i just i'm not an athlete guy i'm not
into it but i know a lot of great
athletes
a lot of really nice people that are
athletes that are world famous
they're good people you can be
competitive on the court and not
off the court you know what i mean so
you can turn it on and off but the
challenge is
that people can't do it um
anyway there's a spectrum of risks
there's a paradigm that i learned about
last year
uh from kyle eschenroder wrote this
wonderful blog piece
and he talks about four things people
think they want to want in life
and he talks about how that's something
that you don't actually want and one of
them
he talks about to do with fame and he
says most people
want to be someone what you should
strive to do
is to do something you don't want to be
someone you want to do something
and it seems like a lot of
upon reading your book a lot of the um
pain which is felt by narcissists is to
do with unlived potential
a gap between what they feel like the
world should be giving them
and what they're getting but obviously
part of that is down to
what are you giving the world a reason
to give you like your actual
output should be reflected back with the
adoration and all of the rest of it
um but what we see you know coming from
a reality tv background which i've been
in
that is the epitome of instantly
becoming someone without having done
anything
so people are given this inflated sense
of self and i think you you talk about
it is
ego inflation they're given this
inflated sense of self
but i think that it's incredibly hollow
you know
i've seen behind the curtain with this
stuff i get to look at
the world the inner world and the outer
world of what a lot of these people talk
about
and there is a big imposter syndrome
that goes around because they know it
was given to them so easily this fame
the millions of followers it was given
to them
essentially and this is the big lie
about reality tv like
they don't deserve it no one deserves it
like elon musk deserves it
conor mcgregor deserves it you know they
deserve tens of millions of followers
because they've
done something they've become someone
their fame
is a byproduct of their success not the
reason
for it caught before horse again
i this is so interesting and um
so when we when we you know this is
going back in time and i forget how old
i'm getting but i first noticed this
with paris hilton
well i'm like my goodness she's one of
the first people i've seen since some of
these 70s people who's famous for being
famous just a celebrity just like uh
just like a queen used to be
and then the kardashians and then
reality television
and there was research done by dr drew
pinsky who's an american like cnn
psychologist guy and a guy mark young is
a professor
southern cal where they gave the
narcissistic personality inventory to
150 or so celebrities on the show
great study and what i loved about it
is at the end they sort of said well
here are the scores and celebrities are
you know relatively high but the highest
scores were reality
reality television and
what's interesting at the time was like
well these are people who are famous
but they're famous for not doing
anything they're just famous for being
famous and so then the question is
who's lining up for this like what's the
what are you lining up for
i mean what do you what are people
lining up for with reality television is
it the fame
or is that fame a launch pad for
sadly something else i wondered about
this um when i went into
love island which was the second reality
tv show i did
there was only two people out of the
entire cast
when i went on who weren't either
unemployed or self-employed
they didn't want reality tv to be a
springboard for their career
they wanted it to be their career this
is my opportunity to be
special i've always felt like because
everybody i think in their heart of
hearts feels like they're unique
right because we only get our own
motivations we view the nuance of our
phenomenological
experience from a front row seat and i
only get to see
the outward things that you say and i'm
like well look at how deep and
meaningful and the unique thoughts
i have because i can't see your deep and
meaningful and unique thoughts
um and i think what it's uh given people
is
look this is your opportunity to be
someone to be unique to be adored
finally everyone is going to see that
that
uh very particular combination of
thoughts and personalities and traits
and everything
else that you have finally you're going
to be able to get your pedestal
from which you can shout about it um but
it's easy come easy go
you know um and that that is personally
where i think if i was a young person
now
looking up to uh role models to want to
become
like you need to look at people who are
scaling over time who are leveraging and
compounding over time
so you need to be looking toward people
the richest guy on the planet
is also going out with grimes right the
richest guy on the planet
he's been on joe rogan he's smoking weed
he's living a good life but
he actually adds value that's the guy
that is compounding
the people that are easy come easy go
hollow the sad point is
there was no equivalent in the past
because we didn't have such frictionless
communication
that meant that you couldn't weaponize
fame in the same sort of speed that we
can now
oh right it is um i mean that's first of
all that's kind of terrifying to me that
you're saying that people want
fame but i mean
i i mean i i i'll tell you a story so
in my life uh i do work and every once
when i get famous but it's for like
a week so it'll be like the biggest i
mean this is going bad like the biggest
story in the world for like
three days and i'll get a bunch of hate
mail and then like i get forgotten
so so i've gone through the fame cycle
bunch
micro fame not real fame no one knows
who i am um
but i had one of my grad students do we
had a paper come out on narcissism and
it was norsemen facebook this
is way back in the day we did the first
study on that and people were very
interested i said go be famous
and the first day she's like this is
awesome this is so much fun i'm talking
to everybody and then a day later she's
like this is
awful one day she's like i've got all
this hate mail
everybody hates me and i'm like exactly
one
day it you got you got to ride the fame
cycle for one day and realize you don't
want to be on it
but how do people know you know how
would you know what fame is like until
you got to do it and
and what they tell kids is you know my
kids are watching i mean my kids are
watching like
australian model shows they're you know
they're probably watching love island
australia because the american shows are
so boring now they have to watch the
australian ones
yeah you know the number one uh aspiring
job that primary school children want
now as a youtuber
i mean i mean i i i love the
entrepreneurship of that but it's just
it's just not a long term like you said
i and very much in investment terms
it's like you could leverage it on
bitcoin it might work
or you could just slowly invest and you
know sort of
cost everything rentals and you know
kind of wait till you're 40 50. you have
some wealth but
it's going to take about 20 30 years
that's just the nature of it
yeah it's interesting man there's a
there's a lot of different rabbit holes
here
um let's talk about other people perhaps
try and give some takeaways some
actionable takeaways
how can we help someone who's a
narcissist to change like is that even
ethical
to to reduce someone's narcissism
well i i mean i don't go around trying
to change anybody for anything that's
just my my general principle in life is
everyone leaves their own life and i'm
not going to tell anyone what to do so
ethically that's how i frame it but
um if people want to change and and
often
you know when we first started studying
narcissism when i first started doing
this i thought people are narcissistic
they're kind of into it and they don't
want to change because it's working for
them
and i thought that for a long time but
with the recent research what we're
seeing
is that people are narcissistic often
see
that their interpersonal antagonism is
costing them in life
basically they go my relationships
aren't as good as some other people's
because i'm kind of an arrogant jerk
and i'd love to be able to have more
connection have more love especially
when you get older you know imagine
being 50 and single and hitting the bar
i mean it just it just sounds
i'm sorry i was at a bar like two weeks
ago and i'm like
my god i spent my whole life trying to
get out of this place i'm not coming
back
um but uh but but so they
so there's this realization so what do
you do what do you do well
therapy seems to work for narcissism
i didn't think that at first it seems to
work but the challenge is that people
have to stick with it and what you see
with
people are narcissistic going to therapy
and they go this isn't working for me
this person doesn't get how unique and
special i am
so one thing is to um you know therapy
is a great idea but the other thing is
and that's what i talk about in the book
is figure out what the problem is if
your problem is love we'll focus on love
you can still be exciting and
charismatic and
and a killer and an adventurer and try
to win and competitive
and love you know they they're not these
things aren't at war with each other
um so my advice is usually don't you
don't have to worry about your arrogance
just focus on being connected to people
and if you get that connection your
arrogance will take care of itself
is there a time where you would ever
prescribe someone to have more
narcissism
yeah oh yeah um i should i said that too
quickly didn't i but i
i just love free narcissism for everyone
yeah well so like in my job
as an academic the way it works is
you're a student and then to go get
hired you have to go around to
these different universities and do job
talks so they'll fly you in to
university of let's say southampton in
england where my advisor is
i'd spend two days meeting everybody on
campus meet the dean meet the faculty
meet the students and i'd do a talk or
two
the people who are successful at that
are confident and charismatic and
extroverted
they're sort of narcissistic um so
you need to have that ability to carry
yourself in a confident way to succeed
it's crazy it's not the way we should
select academics we should select them
on what they
do not how they perform in public but we
select them that way
so cases like that where you need public
performance where you need to meet
people
where you're competitive and like you've
got gotta have some confidence you gotta
have some ego you gotta go into it
and so i'm narcissism is not
bad it is a trade-off and it's really
useful in some
situations the problem is when you start
thinking you're like you start owning it
like i'm better than
everybody i really am better i'm really
famous i'm really more special than
these other real
like we're not we're not that great i
mean
they might remember elon musk
not remembering me richest rich richest
guy on the planet yeah
right it's interesting
how especially in this world and you
know this is going
out on youtube thousands of people are
going to be watching this on youtube
plus
you know even more on audio listening on
audio
and one thing that i've realized over
the last couple of years especially as
video has become frictionless for
communicating with people
and especially the audio platforms have
kicked off
precision of speech and confidence in
your own words
is used as a proxy for truthfulness and
capacity
so the more able that you are to
articulate the things that you're saying
the more truthful people presume the
things that you're saying are
and that it's not
quite narcissism but i think it's the
same sort of model or shape
in that there is this outward display
and someone is making an inference that
goes deeper
from that yes and
um i mean that's not unusual this is
what you see with a lot of
you know added in the old attitudes
research is we trust people
who are attractive and seem like they're
competent even if it's another area
and also people whose arguments look
confident so there's you can dress up
things now
and make them appear to be to be
uh like you said substantial but they
don't aren't necessarily substantial but
people aren't reading philosophy deeply
anymore like when i was a kid i mean i i
shouldn't
i sound like an old guy i'm an old guy
but like
i remember reading plato's republic
because i was like on vacation i'm like
what else am i going to do
you know it's got plato in two days i
don't
get the sense people are doing all that
deep philosophical reading because
there's too much other things to do
i'm not doing it because i'd rather turn
on a youtube show and check my email in
the morning drink coffee
so our our whole way of conversing has
gone from sort of books to these
to youtubes i love youtube podca
podcasting and youtube and i think it's
a great way to
to have discussions and i really like
what i'm doing i love the format
but it's very hard for people to know
the truth
because you're just looking at what's on
the surface and and people aren't
reading the science and they're not
reading the philosophy and i'm like
please do that you can go to google
scholar and find everything yeah
everything's out there now
read i wonder what is going to happen
long term with this
it really does feel like the structure
of narcissism this um have you heard of
the term fronting do you know what
fronting is
with people like opposers kind of yeah
kind of it's it's
basically narcissism it would be
narcissism that was unjustified
so it would be all show no grow
basically okay
okay and um it does really feel like
i don't know whether it's peaked i think
the pandemics definitely put a dampener
on it you know there's there's only so
much that you can flex when you're
locked down in your house or gotta wear
a mask when you're outside
but it definitely felt for a long time
throughout the back end of sort of the
2010s
that this was really picking up speed
that it was more about the transactional
transient nature of how flash and how
quick
witted you could be even when you think
about public intellectuals now
so let's think about jordan peterson or
ben shapiro two sort of
popular public intellectuals um both of
those guys
their highest levels of popularity are
reached when they dunk on someone
on tv because of them being quick-witted
and ben shapiro are saying well why
aren't you 60
or jordan peterson like ha gotchuring
like
the those guys have done shapiro's
slightly less because he's not an
academic but he's you know he's a lawyer
he's
got a doctor of law uh and john peterson
has been lecturing in
psychology for years he's a clinical uh
psychiatrist right
he didn't get famous for doing that he
got famous for like the flashy
charismatic gotcha moment um yeah
and because of that race to the bottom i
wonder i wonder what is going to happen
long term i'm
i'm so fascinated for the the next
decade
i think technology is going to be
interesting to see what direction that
goes in automation
loss of meaning this anomie normlessness
loss of traditions
let's bundle all of this together right
increasingly secular society
uh people getting married later fewer
people having children fewer people
getting married
women having careers right through and
not having children like
man this next 10 years is going to be
i think it's going to be like nothing
else i
um i follow all those the data on
marriage and childlessness
and i see a huge amount of atomization
like just people isolated and living
alone and trying to find meaning on
their own and
and we've been writing about this a long
time but just sort of this rampant
individualism but we got rid of religion
so there's no more religion and so what
happens is you have this space so what
comes in well there's been this huge
interest in spirituality that's come in
huge i mean it's just like the
psychedelic work and that is
that is enormous now because they got
rid of religion you know so people are
jumping on all sorts of stuff to fill it
up
and the other thing i i guess is
where i wonder is where the hell are
people going to find meaning
like if you have a world that's all just
networks and atoms where do you find
meaning if you get rid of religion
you get rid of tradition and you don't
have kids when you have kids
you have to redo everything so when you
have kids you're like i gotta take my
kids to church
i've been to church in 20 years but i'm
gonna go back oh man i gotta go to the
local school and then you're walking
your kid down the street you're talking
you know so having kids re-socializes
people to engage in society
but if you have half or third you know a
third or half or more the people not
even chill children they never engage
it's just they're just gone
i don't know i mean it's it's
it and and i'll throw out two other
things just to
to um um
the other thing that i think is an issue
is we're all on social media
and we feel like we're talking to each
other on social media like i'm having a
discussion with you
but really what we're doing is we're
making networks in a giant
super brain a giant super association
network like twitter is a giant super
association network
association networks are like dumb
brains they're like the dumb
stereotyping part of your brain you have
that makes quick decisions
and and stereotypes and heuristics but
it doesn't think clearly and we've
created like a massive
dumb brain and and we think we're
engaging with people but we're not
i and that's how i take it like i think
i'm with twitter and having a
conversation but i'm really just a
network
in a giant meta node and it's and i'm
creating something bigger than me
whereas this feels like an actual
discussion
what was the cycle that is that pardon
what was the second thing he said you
had two things
i probably just totally lost and i'm
sorry that's that's that's absolutely
yeah i'm just really like i just feel
like everybody's drifting off
and i don't know the forces that are
going to bring people together and it
scares me a little bit because there's
so much room for forces to come in and
start doing that job
man we could this is a whole other
podcast episode but
let's think about um how
politically affiliated people are how
vehement they are patriotic about their
different political affiliations
uh movements like blm antifa how much
people support
sports teams now you people have a
religious fervor around their sports
team
they do think about what it used to be
you would go to the same place the same
day of the week every single week
that would be church on a sunday well
it's the stadium on a saturday now you
don't even
when you can't go see live sport you can
still have your
reddit thread or your whatsapp or
telegram or signal group chat with the
other fans that are seasoned ticket
holders while you watch the game on tv
other things that people are sort of
bowing themselves at the church of and i
think is a good thing is the church of
marcus aurelius
copies of meditation sold out at the
beginning of 2020
sold out couldn't get them on amazon
that's amazing
that's selling a book out and i had uh
well i mean a book that's a thousand
years i don't know
2 000 years old two and a half years
nearly 2 000 years old i had donald
robertson on scottish
uh stoic philosopher and a philosophy
expert
he's also cbt trained um which gives him
a very unique insight
and he was saying when he talks to uh
people who are trendy and now into
stoicism
a lot of them have actually had cbt
before and he asks them so why
why are you so interested in stoicism
they say well what i wanted was like
was like cbt but bigger you know what i
wanted was like
western yoga with the spiritual side
like that's what they want and what all
of these different things whether it's
the sport whether it's the political
movement whether it's the
uh animal liberation movement veganism
climate change
i want belonging i want a sense of
structure i want a linear sense of
progression i want an example from role
models and people that have come before
me that tell me what i'm supposed to do
and someone's looking to a roman emperor
that's been dead for 2000 years
sometimes
i have i mean i i've kind of vacillate
now between like real
pessimism and real optimism about things
because i'm like
because i kind of see the old world
dying and you see the new world coming
in
and you just don't know how it's going
to work out yeah and on one hand
i see people just breaking every i just
look around and people are depressed and
they're
isolated and what we're doing to people
is just i mean as a psychologist
this is god awful i mean isolating
people keeping them
out of the sun and having them order
food i mean it's just
geez it's destroying people
but i've had so many conversations and
that the
interest and spiritual growth and you
know in stoicism
or psychedelics or yoga i mean this
stuff is
people are like trying to find something
and so it's this really interesting time
where they kind of controlled all the
standard stuff
and that non-standard stuff's coming in
and i don't know how it's going to shake
out i really don't but we're in a
when a major transition i think that the
the pandemic
it's an absolute catastrophe and for the
people that have lost loved ones and
family members and stuff
is not good but i really think it put
the brakes on some quite malignant parts
of
modern society as well i said earlier on
you can't flex with a face mask on
like you can't show off your brand new
rolls-royce when you're not allowed out
of your house to drive it
uh and i think it's reminded us all you
know how many people have spent more
time being in touch with their family
because they're terrified they're going
to die
i'm aware that holding a viral gun to
the head of your mother or grandmother
isn't necessarily the best motivation
for it but perhaps it's reminded us
exactly what sort of matters and um
yeah i i don't think that a a pandemic
isn't necessarily the optimal strategy
for causing that to happen within a
civilization
but in terms of trying to find silver
linings in the cloud i definitely think
that that could be one of them
do you think that i mean i get that same
sense too when i
talk to my kids because i'm always
trying to figure out kid culture so i
asked my own kids i don't really
you know um and i i noticed this the
fashion is
really kind of boring almost 1930s style
a lot of 1980s
kind of mom fashion i see him wearing
that's very i mean it reminds me what my
mom were so i don't hate it but it's
very
boring it's not really showy so
i got the sense that people like you
said aren't flexing as much
and i wonder if the pandemic hastened
the change we were going through
or if it's just as soon as the
pandemic's gone it's like a recession
when everyone's like when is the
recession they're like back to
simplicity and then as soon as the
recession's over they're like after i
get back from my holiday in spain
yeah i think a big part of it's that
there was something you said earlier on
i totally forgot to bring this up
in a world where everybody is trying to
be pushy and showy and flex online and
play the look at me role
there's a place for narcissism
to manifest in someone being overly
subtle
the person that's like the aloof muse in
the corner of the room you know he's got
his elephant pants on and a sleeveless
t-shirt and
he doesn't need that man like you know
i'm not part of that man
like that's not my thing man like that
kind of approach and you think it's just
different routes for people trying to
find the uniqueness and this is
like i am completely folly i speak
to the internet three nights a week in
an effort to do the same thing
i want people to hear what i've got to
say but i
the more that we become aware of our
cognitive biases in this way
i think the more that we can get closer
to what a true sense of virtue is
yeah i um i have you know i
i wrestle with my own need for fame and
attention a lot
and um and one i can see it i i don't
know what elephant pants are but they
sound what are
you know those uh when you see people go
to thailand and they're kind of like
wide
oh yeah with the elephant so yes
yes gotcha yeah so what happens is
like we're all in the same status race
because that's part of life
we're all in it we can't not be in it
that's just the nature of it so what i
look at it is like
are you going to get attached to it or
you're not going to get attached to it
if you start getting attached to fame
if you get attached to fame you're dead
that's right tell people because once
you get your
name you're going to get that hit off
the crack pipe and you're going to say i
need another hit
and you're going to say i need your head
and you're only going to get two or
three in your life
and then you're going to die alone
chasing that fourth hit maybe
i'd love to hear what you think but i am
like fame is great but whatever you do
do not get attached to it because
it ain't and i don't know what you're
but so i'm telling people's like go have
fun but if you start thinking this
stuff's real
it'll it'll eat you alive for me i sent
a little panic there
no not at all for me i think it's
use the fame but know that it's not
about the fame
um there's a a really a really good
quote and this is
this is to do with money but it works
for fame as well
um making life all about money
is like making a road trip all about the
gas stations
like you wouldn't go on a road trip and
just visit every different gas station
that you could that's not the
point you need the money to keep going
and it's a useful tool to ensure that
your road trip doesn't stop
but you don't do a tour of gas stations
and i think that you can apply that
analogy to fame as well
the fame of these it's this little
bouncing on a
on a trampoline and each time you bounce
maybe you can bounce a little bit higher
and bounce a little bit higher and
bounce a little bit higher
but it's not about the fame and i did
man this is coming from some of the free
charcoal toothpaste on instagram the
blue tick on twitter like all that sort
of stuff like been there seeing it done
it got the t-shirt
um but it's facilitated me to do
some things but i'm so glad that i never
started to swallow my own [ __ ] with
regards to that
uh and a perfect a perfect example that
these the listeners might kind of be
able to relate to is that
when you're on tv when you're famous for
essentially having done nothing
like being someone not doing something
all of the praise that you get is hollow
you don't
feel love you feel praise and the reason
is that you're playing a persona it's a
role on tv
whereas if i get a message from
listeners to the show
telling me about how it's affected them
or something they liked
that like hits me in the feels so hard
this guy came up to me at a fitness expo
six months after i started the show
and he was telling me that um his dad
had recently passed away
and the episode with corey allen that i
did
corey allen um had reminded him that it
made him realize
that he was um
distancing himself from his father's
death and not fully
uh accepting that it happened and that
was causing him and his fa that was
causing him to be a bad dad and a bad
husband and he came up and he said i
just wanted to
told me this story mine is what i did
thank you and so you can imagine at this
fitness expo
so i've been like going to the gym for
months i mean i got my top off
everyone's training there's like
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people there
and i'm weeping in front of this guy
and i'm like this guy's just fully torn
me up because i was like
alpha mailing around having this good
time and this dude came in and totally
sideswiped me like a [ __ ] articulated
lorry
and i'm there in front of him and i'm
like protect like do i pretend not to
cry like am i trying to like not do this
thing like sort of
pretending i've got an itch on my head
doing it every five seconds
and um that to me like that story
it gave me meaning in a way that i'd
never felt before
i hadn't got that when someone goes man
you know when you wore those shorts on
love island the orange ones not the not
the light orange ones the darker orange
ones and you walked down those stairs
it was so meaningful i was lost and
alone and in this place of existential
dread but after i saw you in those shots
that doesn't change i'm going to be
shallow i was like i'm done chris
i'm just going to be shallow the rest of
my life
doesn't happen right no yeah
but this is a thi like what you're doing
on these podcasts is authentic it's what
it sounds like
you can't talk to this and not be man
like if you if you tried to play persona
for
four hours a week you would be fully
exhausted
right and so that's what i i really
enjoy podcasting
and i don't really talk to media i'm not
that they're asking me to talk to them
but
but i i don't find it that useful but i
find these more useful because they seem
more authentic
because like you said you can't really
fake it for an hour that's interesting
to hear i
i never could act i just couldn't i
can't really fake it at all
i mean i can put on a i can do an act
it's performance but
it's close to truth you know yeah i
think
i think that this movement that we've
got here towards stoicism towards
spirituality towards psychedelics
consumption of long-form content people
learning how to read again there's like
a reading movement there's even a
bookstagram
movement on instagram which is people
who basically run book clubs
and talk about the books that they're
reading and then do book summaries on
instagram as well and they all discuss
it in the comments below
uh get better with books jim mullane my
buddy's been on the show fantastic guy
and um all of this i think is a counter
culture
movement i think it's people realizing
that the hyper normal stimuli
and the dopamine uh manipulation that
we're having
people want less oddly for the first
time in ever people want less
i um well it i i when i
you know i'll put on like bob dylan
albums from the 60s sometimes and they
make sense that's how crazy things are
i'm like god i finally understood
subterranean's homesick blues in 2021
you know that's how crazy it is
but um i sense this counterculture too
and i really glad you see it but what's
interesting to me is the people doing
the psychedelics aren't the same people
that were doing them
when i was at berkeley they're like the
country guys
and the in the folk it's a we it's weird
it's like it's the it's the
it's like the sides kind of changed in a
way
and um and so it's very hard to see
you know but it's but it's happening and
it's really it's just
anyway it's very powerful i don't know
how this is going to shake out but what
you're saying makes me feel good
that people are thinking next decade's
going to be interesting keith today's
been awesome man the new science of
narcissism
will be linked in the show notes below
on amazon where else do you want to send
people
oh any place w dot com
basically i'm not very good at fame i
apologize
just google me that's fine i'll uh i'll
throw what i can find if you want
little tiny little fragments of your
tiny fragments digital ghost platform
that you've got i'll
i'll get them and i'll throw them in the
show notes below thank you very much for
today mate
thank you yeah